- Yeah, I'm gonna take
you back to your about
I'd say, it was the
summer of 89, maybe 90.
Yeah. I was maybe about 16
years old, 17 years old.
And you know, I used to live
in this apartment complex.
We moved over there.
I was on the run, you know what I mean?
I was running some serious (beep)
that I mentioned before, you know.
I was running and running
and they chased me all the way
to Arizona, matter of fact,
they went up there, you know,
the detectives looking for me,
they went all the way to Arizona.
So, they wanted me pretty bad.
While I was in this apartment complex.
And it was pretty big.
It maybe had like 300 units in it
and it was real cool, you know.
The manager right there
got high and everything.
So, I set right in just fine, you know,
and at that time I was
moving, you mean some (beep)
and there was no glass
back then or none of that.
It was, lemon drop and
peanut butter crank.
I was moving that
and I was doing it, doing it, doing it.
And I met these broads
along the way from dealing dope,
you know, I met these girls
and they had their own
little, little homegirls set.
You know what I mean?
They were from the hood
right there where I was from
you know, they're enemies,
but these were their homegirls
and I didn't mind kicking it with them.
So we're kicking it and
I was hearing, you know,
through other people
that one of these girls,
she was real, real devious.
You know, she used to set fools up,
get fools caught up, you know,
do some scandalous (beep).
Well, you know, I guess after
a while when I was
(beep) around with them,
I think I messed with two of them,
and they got upset and one of them went
and told her homeboy that, you know,
That I what I was over here in this spot
and it was kind of close to their hood.
And I used to lock the gates
in the morning and let people out to work.
You know, I had the whole
apartment set up, you know.
We used to call it the Roman Empire.
That's what we used to call it.
And we're doing it up in there.
And I had got my wife pregnant,
so we're about to have
a baby shower, you know.
So we have this baby shower
and I'm inside the house.
I remember I'm inside the house
and I'm inside the kitchen
and I'm rolling some joints on
the counter, in the kitchen.
And I heard a knock at the door.
So I looked to see who it is.
And in walks these four dudes,
I remember their faces, man.
You know, it was like yesterday, you know,
came back to my head that
this had occurred with me.
No, 'cause everything
I'm giving you on tape,
it's the truth, man.
You know, I ain't tryna (beep) nobody.
Well, I'm in there rolling a joint
and in they walk in and I
recognize these dudes, man.
I'm like, Oh man. They
got me, man. They got me.
You know, 'cause these dudes,
they always got heat on them.
You know what I mean?
They're always looking to
get somebody, you know.
So they already had some fools
that they chalked up along the way.
And I'm like, they got me, man.
These (beep) got me.
I'm inside this house, I
don't got nothing on me.
You know what I mean?
I'm at a baby shower.
In they walk and they walk right past me.
And we walked past me
and my little homeboy
from my hood, he's sitting
on one of those lazy boys.
And they walk up, a dude walks up to him
and tells him, hey, calls
him by his first name
and he tells him, I
know we know each other
for a long time, but you know
what, man, (beep) your hood,
he tells my little homie, right?
So, I'm looking like,
my little homie says,
man, (beep) your hood.
My little homie gets up.
My homie tell them, well lets go outside.
So, I thought that dude was
gonna do my homie right there,
'cause dude has a reputation
of just taking fools straight out the box.
So I'm like, man, you know,
he tells my little homie that
they start to walk outside.
And as they're walking out behind me
I'm looking for anything
to grab, you know?
I mean, I'm thinking,
I gotta get something.
And I noticed the
chopping block, you know?
And in the kitchen, they
got this big old block
of wood and it has all the knives in it.
You know what I mean?
So I grabbed the biggest handle I see
and I pulled it out and
it's that big butcher knife.
So, as they walk out, I
grabbed the butcher knife.
I stopped my little cousin on the way out.
I tell him, "Here, here.
Put in your jacket,
put in your jacket".
He puts in his jacket.
I go to grab the next
knife and I'm pulling out.
And man, when it comes
out, it's that flimsy one.
The one you cut the bread with.
I'm like, oh my God,
what? Oh my God, what?
And I pulled out, I went
to pull the next one out.
It didn't come out.
I pulled it up. Bam, here it came.
It was the big meat cleaver,
the one the Chinese, you know,
use to chop all the fish and (beep).
Well, you know what I mean?
I get that one.
I slide it in my jacket, boom,
and I make my way outside.
As I'm getting outside, you
know, it's a baby shower,
so you know, a lot of girls are there.
You know, my aunts, my cousins, everybody.
It's my wife's baby shower,
so they're all there.
And I see my aunt in the middle
of my cousin and this dude,
these four guys, and she's
telling the guy, kick back
kick back, you know?
So as I'm walking up, I'm looking
and I see this one guy
just reach back say, "Man, (beep) you".
And he slaps my aunt.
Now, as soon as he slapped
my aunt, I was like, Oh.
I knew that this dude was in trouble, man.
I had to break this guy up.
That's my aunt, you know what I mean?
I ain't tryna hear (beep) from my uncle.
Oh, now his little sister got slapped.
I ain't tryna get (beep) off.
So, I walk up to these fools
and as soon as he slaps my
aunt, I'm already up on them.
I reach out to grab the dude.
When I reach out to grab
the dude, I grabbed him
by his shirt and I'm gonna
take this fools head off.
I got that meat cleaver, I'm
gonna chop his head right off.
You know, he slapped my aunt.
Anybody, you know, that
knows when you're growing up
in the hood, you got family
members from the hood.
You know, if somebody puts
hands on your family member
you know that that's a big no-no
in anybody's book, I could imagine.
That's a no, no in my book.
So when I go to chop this
fools face right off,
my aunt goes to slap this dude
and we connect at the same time. Boom.
And I get my aunts hand, like about,
I say about this far down.
I mean, it's a big wound
but as soon as I hit it, I kinda stopped.
And when I pulled out, man,
I'm like, Oh I hear her scream,
but I still got the dude by the shirt.
So I get the dude and
I'm so mad, you know.
And I just started swinging this.
And you know, when I was
swinging and I actually
didn't feel anything hitting
no flesh, no shoe, nothing.
I mean pants, nothing.
I didn't feel (beep).
Well, as soon as I'm
hitting him, I see one
of the other four dudes,
he's running up towards me.
So I pushed the dude to the side.
I guess when I pushed
the dude to the side,
my little cousin was behind
me with that big butcher knife
and just let that fool have it.
Boom hit him.
I guess he hit the ground. I don't know.
But the second dude came and
I remember he had this knife
you know, he had like
one of those buck knife's
that you carry, you know,.
It's not that long, but he went to stab me
with it and I just stuck
my hand out, you know like.
And for some reason his
fist hit right in my hand
and the knife just like
right between the fingers.
I mean, it was right there where I had it
and I was like, what the (beep)?
I had his hand and I said, I
hit him about two, three times
on the side, right here (mumbling).
He falls down, right. He falls down.
Well, when he falls down
another dudes coming to rush me.
'Cause when he come to rush
me, I just swing that thing.
And I swear, man, this
hit like right on the top
of his forehead, back into his head.
And that's pretty big.
It's a ball about like that.
You know what I mean?
So you know what I mean?
It's gonna do some damage.
They're really sharp.
If you've seen them and
you look at the (beep),
they're like a Ginsu, you know?
They call it, yeah, they
call it the meat cleaver.
Well, I hit this dude and
it hits his head, boom.
And as soon as he hit his head, you know
I feel somebody grabbing
me, I guess, to stop me.
You know, 'cause there's a lot of people
but remember there's a lot of women there.
There's not really many men
there 'cause it's a baby shower.
So, as he pulls me back,
I remember when I go back
and I just feel that blade just come out.
Like it made a weird noise,
like (making the sound)
and as soon as it came
out, blood just squirts.
Now when the blood squirt,
the blood squirt all on me,
on my face, you know what I mean?
My hands, all my shirt, my pants
his bloods squirts on me
and I was like, what the (beep)?
When I came to, I'm looking around man.
And I'm like, what the, what's going on?
I can't see, 'cause the bloods
in my eyes and my face,
so I try to wipe it out.
I'm trying to look
and when I look to the side,
the first dude that initially,
the one that slapped my aunt,
my head pauses, I gotta
get this fool, you know?
'Cause I'm not done with him.
You know what I mean?
His homeboy can't stop the process
of me (beep) this dude up..
Well, as soon as I turned around to look,
there's this guy and his homies,
the other two that were there.
They pick him up and when they pick him
up off the floor, you know, it,
when they pick him up
it reminds me of when the
incredible Hulk, you know
when he gets real big
and then he gets down
to regular man's size again,
his clothes are just shredded.
Well, this is how that fool looked.
when they picked him up.
His clothes were just
hanging from his body.
I guess when I hit him with that thing,
later I found out that
I hit him a lot of times
but it's like a big razor blade.
So I guess when I was going through,
I wasn't really feeling anything.
But you know, when you cut
yourself with a razor blade,
it gets like white and then
pink then blood comes out,
seeps real slow, you know?
'Cause remember, I wanna
get this dude again.
I didn't think I got him too good.
Apparently I got him real good
because he was in the hospital
for like two, three days.
You know what I mean?
And he had a gang of slices on him.
You got the forehead shot, you know?
And it's trippy.
'Cause all these dudes, you know,
back when I was growing up, you know,
these three guys right
here, were some pretty tough
you know, out of their
hood, out of their area.
You know, they, you know one
of the dudes there, you know,
he, I always don't say no
names, give no ins to who it is.
You know, I'm just letting it be known.
This is some real (beep).
These fools right here,
were, how can we say, erasing
(beep) as we're going along.
You know what I mean?
That's the best way I
can say it. You know?
And I knew this and a
couple of these people
that these guys got were
my childhood friends.
You know what I mean?
And you know what I mean?
I always wanted to get this dude
but I always had to be cautious
because these guys, man
they just have weapons, man.
They all went and did life sentences.
Think one of them did like 20
and got out a couple of years back.
But you know, when I got these dudes,
once I came to, and I see
them walk this guy away,
I look to the side.
And I remember the look
in my, not just my grandma
my aunts eyes, but my
mother-in-law was there
and my sister-in-law, you know.
And they're all sitting around
and they're just looking
at me and I can imagine how I look, man.
You know what I mean?
I'm full of blood.
I did this to these
dudes and I was like, man
I'm looking, I'm like,
I'm getting married.
I want to marry this lady's daughter.
Then you just seen me, you know,
chop these three dudes
up with a meat cleaver.
And you know, the reason
I did it really was
because the way the dude reached
back and he slapped my aunt
you know, he slapped her pretty good.
You know what I mean?
He slapped her very well.
You know well, the way I found
out about the guy that I got,
the first one I got is
'cause my aunt had to go
to the doctor to sew her hand up.
You know what I mean?
And they try to connect
the (beep) and whatever
but it didn't work.
Well, these dudes, I know, I knew after
that I had to look out for them.
You know, I had to watch them.
You know, make sure they
ain't come and get me.
Eventually, I was kicking
back, it was like midnight.
And I'm kicking back right
there with the homie,
we was just smoking some (beep).
And then I tell him, I'm
gonna go upstairs real quick.
So, you know, as I go upstairs,
I'm gonna go get my thing
I put away, you know.
I put it behind the heater in
the house. I'm gonna get it.
And all of a sudden outside,
I hear some, some voices.
So I go to the back window
and I look out and low and behold,
it's two of the guys
that came that one day,
two right there.
They got these two fools
that I was kicking it with.
And I see this dude with a shotgun.
He has a shotgun out
on one of the guys, man
and he's questioning him.
You know, I'm looking
down and I'm like, man,
my mother-in-law is
asleep in the next room.
If I go out my window and
shoot at these dudes, man,
I'm gonna get caught.
You know what I mean?
Everybody's gonna get up.
I'm gonna get caught. I live here.
I can't do that.
So I listen in man and I hear
this dude telling this guy, man.
He's asking for me, I'm like (beep).
He's asking for me.
The dude's telling him that it's not him.
Dude showing him his tattoos and (beep).
'Cause the dudes from East LA.
So he showing him tattoos and
and the dude tells him,
yeah well, you know,
you let Johnny know that
we're coming looking for him.
So I was like, man, you know what I mean?
Now, it's getting to something bigger.
You know what I mean?
And he has this other dude
with him, that's kind of older.
And I'm like, oh wait up.
You know what I mean?
He brought his older homie with him.
Something must be amiss here.
So I go and I want to investigate
what the (beep) is going on
because I'm curious, because
the older guy came, you know.
I'm a youngster like this
dude, you know, we're dealing
with our mess and this older
guy is getting involved.
I wanna find out what's going on.
Well, I had some family members
that were from that hood.
So I questioned, you
know, what was going on.
Low and behold, I find out
that this guy told his homies
that I caught him, I set him up
in the backyard and it's cool.
You know what I mean?
I told him to come over
and kick it and get high
and drink and all that.
It's all (beep), 'cause
we don't get along.
I would never tell the guy
to come kick it with me.
I know his reputation.
I know what he's capable of.
I mean, I heard through the grapevine
for $5 he's (beep) off some fool.
You know, for five bucks.
And I was like, man, this
dude's real treacherous.
So, I would've never
invited that fool anywhere,
you know what I mean?
I would've never took
him with me anywhere.
But he stated that,
so now, his older homies,
they're looking for me now.
So I'm like, wait up, man.
This fool went and lied
and this, you know?
Never ever did he ever put in there
that he put hands on my aunt?
Never. He never ever put that in there
but I knew that that
was my ACE in the hole.
You know, he, once he
did that act right there,
I could do anything I wanted to him.
He was gonna be in trouble anyways.
But once we went, once I
seen his homies and they
you know, they came,
strapped up to get me.
You know what I mean?
They came to get me.
I was at a barbecue pit,
you know what I mean, I had
a little something with me
but there was about five of them.
They all had straps and
they came to get me.
And I told the older dude that was there.
I told him, man, you know,
the only reason I did that
to him, was because, you know
he put hands on my aunt
and he slapped my aunt
The older dude looked at
me like, what do you mean?
And he said, who's your aunt.
I told him who my aunt was,
he knew exactly who she was
because she was married to one
of his homeboys years back.
So he go in, they get this fool
and you know, they tell him
and whatever he gives
this story, whatever.
I don't see these fools no more.
Well, I get busted and I
was on the run for that.
I told you what I get busted.
And I get to the County,
I'm in the chow hall
and I'm eating and I
see this fool walk in.
I'm like, oh, I got him.
I mean, I'm in the County.
I got to heat or I got this fool.
Well, I told him, you know,
hey meet me at the escalator.
You know?
'Cause I seen him.
I told him, hey man, you're talking,
come on meet me at the escalator.
And I figured he was gonna come.
I figured he was gonna come because
he's a gang member, you
know, he's with the business.
But sometimes out there on the streets
and many people know that,
anybody could pull a trigger out there.
Anybody, you know, there's
any people out there
pull triggers, 15, 14 years
old, they just pull it
just because, they want
to see somebody get hurt.
You know what I mean?
Me, I was kind of different, you know?
And the only reason I got
a weapon that one time was
because of the fact that
these guys had a reputation
of doing bad things to people.
And I didn't want to be
one of those statistics
where they got me and they got me good.
Another thing was from the
beginning, when he came
he came in, you know, he
entered the baby shower.
He didn't enter no party.
There was no DJ, lights
and everything going on.
So, you know, he came to hurt me.
So I hurt him, you know what I mean?
And I found out how they were, you know
I see the dude later in time
he didn't come to the escalator
that time I called him in the County.
He didn't come, you know,
and he knows who he is.
So I'm like, sick of your (beep).
He didn't come, man.
After that, way after
that, I seen him again,
you know what I mean?
And we were riding on one tank
he got another tank and he was talking.
And I told him, show these fools
what I did to you, take
your shirt off, you know?
And he took it off.
And this fool had zippers
that were tattooed on him,
I guess, everywhere I sliced
him with the meat cleaver.
He had zippers on there, tattooed
and he had a lot of zippers, man.
This fool had a lot of zippers
and we know he was upset.
You know what I mean?
He got more upset when I told him
take your shirt off in the holding tanks.
And the homies were in there with him.
So he had to take his shirt off.
He had no choice
but that's what he gets
for having a big mouth.
You know, this dude, I heard
that he went and did 20 something years
and he got out, you
know recently, you know,
so, you know, parts of being a gangster,
like I always say, there's good
parts and there's bad parts.
I didn't enjoy hurting this dude, Mark.
But the thing about it was
is that, the steps he took
and the things he did only
made me, you know what I mean?
I had an obligation to
take care of this fool.
You know what I mean?
And you know, I mean, stabbing
this fool that many times,
I feel that he had it coming,
but at the same time, you know,
afterwards I felt kind of bad.
Yeah. That I did that, you know?
'Cause a lot of times when I
did (beep), being a gangster
and growing up the lifestyle
that I went through
with all my family, being gang members
a lot of the (beep) I did,
I didn't do it because
I really liked doing it.
I did it because by obligation
and I knew that if I
didn't do it, you know
I would get scolded by my family.
You know, not just my
hood, but by my family.
And they're all my
homies and I wasn't gonna
come home saying I didn't
do this or I didn't do that
because you know, well I didn't want.
No, most of the (beep) I
did, because by obligation.
You know what I mean?
And that was part of being a gangster.
And I think that comes
kind of on the bad side
because sometimes you don't
feel like doing (beep)
and sometimes (beep) just comes up.
You know what I mean?
You know, situations come up like that one
you know what I mean?
And I didn't go look for
nobody, start no (beep).
This dude came because
it's homegirl told him
because she was upset because
I'm messing with both of them,
her and her homegirl.
So they get upset, tell
their homie where I'm at.
You know, then he comes
over here to get me
but low and behold, I got his ass.
You know what I mean?
And those stories come back to me.
When I meet people from
when I was a youngster
I seen a dude the other
day and he told me, man,
we were rapping and this story
came up to my head and I was like, Ooh
I gotta tell Mark about this one
because this one right
here was a good one.
You know, they just pop
in my head simultaneously.
And you know, I share 'em because not just
because I glorify being a gang member
or I glorify being from a gang, nah
it's more or less like
this happened in my life.
And it's the truth.
And you know, these dudes
didn't die or have brain damage
or anything no more, no they're
back normal and everything.
I'm back, normally and everything.
But this just happened to us.
You know, because of
the lifestyle we chose
you know what I mean?
And being a gangster,
I seen a lot of videos.
I look at a lot of videos and you know
a lot of people glorify
it and keep glorifying it.
You know what I mean?
They never tell you about the bad side.
You know, you always tell
you about the good side.
You know, you got to
know about the bad side
'cause a coin has two sides to it.
You know what I mean?
And I come to share it.
To take you there, Mark, you know
I try to make you feel like you're part
of that scene because you know,
as I tell you stories,
you know what I mean?
More and more come to my head.
You know what I mean?
Like, Oh the next week this
happened, the next week
and a lot of times I forget it.
But a lot of times I see people
and I remember, Oh, I know him.
I remember this happening.
There are stories that I want to tell
because of the fact that people need
to hear (beep) like that.
People need to hear (beep)
that there is a reality
over here on this side
you know what I mean?
It's not just all glamor.
You know what I mean?
Oh, I'm a gangster.
Look at me, look at me.
You know, it's not like that.
There's a lot of parts
where, you know what I mean?
Now this dude did 20 years.
He got out now.
That happened right before he got busted.
So, he could have cut this
(beep) out all this time
all along, you know?
But like I said, I
don't watch over my back
or look over my shoulder and
I ain't got time for that.
You know what I mean?
There's too much time consuming.
I just keep strolling.
But he knows, you know,
he knows where I'm at.
He probably watched this and see it.
You know what I mean?
And he knows it's the truth.
I just wanted to share
with you today, Mark.
You know what I mean?
So I'm like that for you, you
know that one's for you Mark.
- [Mark] All right, Johnny.
- All right, Mark.
I'll tell you Mark, I
got some good (beep).
(Johnny mumbling in the background)